italy earlier today we learned the
border numbers
hit a decade high in this month of march
with the last month of march without
whopping
172 encounters last month with the
illegal migrants that's up from
70 percent from the previous record high
in february
when you compare the numbers under
donald trump this time last year
it was well under 35 000 and it gets
worse
because this week authorities arrested a
suspected ms-13 gang member at the
border
and in recent months border agents
nabbed foreigners on the terror watch
list
from places like yemen and elsewhere so
what exactly will it take for the biden
and harris administration
to take the issue seriously you have
unsanitary conditions
massive overcrowding culver coveted
super spreader conditions
fights breaking and out and now reports
of child
rape known terrorists we have ms-13
gang members and what has been the
response absolutely nothing
there's silence from the white house
silence from joe
kamala chuck nancy the media mob
democrats in general a national disgrace
protecting socialist democrats clearly
now more important than protecting these
kids
and protecting our country and the biden
administration is cramming migrants into
cages
where they are now being abused in large
numbers
and remember joe and barack they first
built the cages for kids in 2014.
remember in 2018 the media mob lied and
said
donald trump did this and then they'd
show the video
fortunately that video was from the
obama biden era now this entire crisis
is self-inflicted it's a catastrophe of
joe biden's own making
he told the migrants to come he provided
incentives for them to come he held out
amnesty as a reward
and he was totally unprepared when they
did come
and he's now closed his eyes and his
ears to any of the problems he has now
caused by the way making conditions at
the border facilities
horrendous law enforcement now is
stretched
razor thin what does that mean that's a
field day
for drug dealers and traffickers and
human traffickers they're cashing in
and all thanks to joe biden's failed
policies
and that is a simple truth now more than
ever it's time to put the safety
security sovereignty
of our nation's borders over biden's
reckless irresponsible
political power hungry political
pandering and perpetual lying that's
going on here with